foreign
[Music]
we take you on an Epic Journey Through
Middle Earth as we talk about the next
movie from the fantasy world the Lord of
the Rings The War of the rohiram the
animated film is set to open a new
chapter in the popular franchise and
takes place far before the well-known
Trilogy it's high time we had a closer
look at the project we hope you enjoy
our new original
the war of the rohiram takes us to an
Era of conflict and heroism in which
Helm hammerhand plays a crucial role as
the ninth king of Rohan Helm Reigns
during a time in which the realm is
fighting against the dunlandings a
notably Fierce race that leader supports
Saruman during the Lord of the Rings
trilogy their leader lord frecka
requires Helm's daughter Hera to marry
his son wolf an offense that will
eventually result in a bloody war
between the clans in this conflict an
important factor will be a fortress that
fans of The Lord of the Rings will
probably be familiar with it will later
be known as Helm's Deep the scene of an
epic battle in The Two Towers but the
film does not revolve around the two
kings only their children are also
pivotal to the story on the one side
there is the wild ruler's daughter Hera
who grows up in the middle of the war
and has to become a Fearless Warrior on
the other side there's Wolf the heir to
the throne of dunland muscular armed
with an ax and with a scarred face the
main villain of the film at the Past
film festival in Tennessee France a
version of the movie was already shown
in June which is why some details about
the war of the rohiram are known mode
for example the culture of the horsemen
will be explored in more detail which is
based primarily on war family power
structures and fights are the main focus
where honor and loyalty are always
considered more valuable than wealth and
material possessions however
Supernatural ghost stories should also
find their place in the story for sure a
topic where the animations can show off
their full potential so far released
concept art also features oliphons and
Orcs surrounding edoras there are images
of Isengard surrounded by tents and
wildfires as well as many background
images of Medusa so we can likely expect
some spectacular scenes in the finished
film by the way despite the fact that
the film is animated and Peter Jackson
is not involved the film exists within
Jackson's Universe which is certainly
pleasing news for fans of the franchise
who are rather disappointed by Amazon's
Lord of the Rings series The Rings of
power which had comparatively little to
do with the cult films
production of The Lord of the Rings The
War of the rohiram was taken over by new
line Cinema and Warner Brothers
animation and has already been in
progress for almost two years the movie
is directed by the renowned anime
director Kenji kamiyama known for his
work on popular animes such as Ghost in
the Shell and Ultraman this is his
second collaboration with Warner
Brothers hacker previously developing
the anime series Blade Runner Black
Lotus but don't worry the recognition
value of the old movies will not be
completely lost Peter Jackson's version
definitely served as visual inspiration
for many scenes in the new film adapting
the world for the new animation style
was one of the crew's biggest challenges
they worked closely with Daniel Faulkner
the art director of the live-action
movies he helped the team find old
models from the original movies and
explain their backgrounds
the cast of The Lord of the Rings The
War of the rohiram includes a mix of
well-known and lesser-known names Brian
Cox known from the series succession
will give his voice to King Helm
hammerhand Luke pasqualino best known
for his role as Freddie McClure in the
series skins will take on the role of
wolf likewise joining the cast is Sean
Dooley whose voice we recognized from
the video game Elden ring he will voice
Wolf's father frecka similar to The
Fellowship of the Ring the movie starts
with an off-screen narration in this
case we hear Owen again played by
Miranda Otto
the Lord of the Rings The War of the
rohiram promises to open an exciting new
chapter in the world of Middle Earth
with its dramatic plot original
animation style and talented voice
actors this movie will hopefully satisfy
both old and new fans of The Lord of the
Rings the movie were released in
theaters on April 12 2024. we hope to
have a first teaser trailer within the
next few months what is your opinion on
this can the universe work as an anime
or does it take it too far away from the
look and feel of the franchise feel free
to drop us a line in the comments
[Music]
thank you